jetzt also die antwort der russen laut
einem bericht der russischen
nachrichtenagentur tass plant moskau
referenten in den sogenannten
volksrepublik in donetzk und lugansk
diese sollen zwischen dem 23 und dem 27
september stattfinden ziel der
referenten ist ein anschluss der
besetzten regionen an russland 2014
hatte russland die ukrainische halbinsel
krim nach einem manipulierten referendum
illegal annektiert und darüber sprechen
wir jetzt mit philippi ad hoc bild
meinung chef hier bei uns im studio
schirm und tag philipp wir werden diese
referenten also diese abstimmungen
ablaufen ja es die sind auf drei bis
vier tage angesetzt in der sogenannten
volksrepublik donetzk lukas und jetzt
auch noch in person in dieser seit
februar besetzten großstadt in der süd
ukraine um die gerade heftig gekämpft
wird und da sollen die bürger abstimmen
ob sie zu russland gehören wollen man
muss aber natürlich dazu sagen das wird
alles komplett fake sein die russen wie
auch bei sich im land werden auch in
diesen sogenannten volksrepublik
natürlich nicht zulassen dass die
menschen irgendeine freie wahl haben
sondern diese gebiete sind besetzt von
russischen truppen das ergebnis steht
also jetzt schon fest wenn russland
irgendwo ein referendum abhält mit genau
das ergebnis rauskommen dass moskau
haben will und diese referenten haben
nur einen einzigen zweck sie sind
kriegstaktik
kriegstaktik das heißt das ziel von
putin ist eindeutig oder absolut diese
republiken sollen sich dafür aussprechen
dass sie unbedingt zu russland gehören
dann wird russland sie in einem
schnellverfahren anschließen an die
russische föderation um dann sagen zu
können jeder angriff viele ukrainische
angriff auf diese sogenannten
volksrepublik ist damit auch ein angriff
auf das kernland russland denn damit
würden diese republiken ja zu russland
gehören und dann könnte russland sagen
wenn ihr uns hier angreift dann müssen
wir eskalieren also beispielsweise
atomwaffen einsetzen nicht dass russland
das tatsächlich vorhat aber die drohung
allein ist schon sehr viel wert und die
hat ehrlich gesagt auch schon begonnen
diese druck kampagne hat schon begonnen
russische propagandisten verbreiten sie
bereits auf twitter und sagen wer uns
nach diesem referendum angreift wer
donetsk oder lugansk oder versonnen nach
diesem referendum attackiert übrigens
legitimer weise attackiert in diese
gebiete sind besetzt also die ukraine
hat hier das recht sie anzugreifen und
zurückzuerobern aber sobald das passiert
wird russland sagen hier greift unser
kern land an die russische föderation
und wir werden uns mit allen mitteln
verteidigen ob mit atomwaffen oder mit
einer generalmobilmachung von der auch
schon lange die rede ist also das ist
ein rein kriegs taktisches referendum
denn russland hätte dieser referenten ja
auch schon im februar im januar also
lange vor dem krieg durchführen können
damals wollte man das noch nicht damals
wollte man offenbar noch viel mehr von
der ukraine erobern jetzt hat man
gesehen dass das nicht so gut
funktioniert dass man überall
zurückgedrängt wird und jetzt will man
mit aller macht in panik sichern was man
noch hat wie werden die ukraine jetzt
wiederum darauf reagieren die ukraine
hat schon erklärt dass diese referenten
in den sogenannten volksrepublik um
überhaupt nichts ändern das bleibt das
ist und das bleibt ukrainisches gebiet
und die ukraine wird weiter darum
kämpfen aber die frage ist natürlich
auch wie wird der westen darauf
reagieren es steht natürlich fest dass
der westen diese referenten nicht
anerkennen wird die werden manipuliert
sein ist man muss überhaupt nicht
darüber sprechen das ist kompletter fake
aber was wird der westen tun wenn der
kreml bald erklärt dass jeder angriff
auf die sogenannte volksrepublik ein
angriff auf russisches kern land
bedeutet wird die nato weiterhin oder
nicht die nato bei einzelnen nato
staaten werden die weiterhin waffen
liefern werden sie weiterhin sagen dass
die ukraine jedes recht hat weiter zu
kämpfen oder werden sie es nicht doch
mit angst zu tun bekommen und sagen dass
die ukraine vielleicht doch lieber mit
russland verhandeln sollte das ist die
große frage also lassen wir uns von
putin einschüchtern von dieses
referenten oder nicht sagte bild meinung
chef philipp iad herzlichen dank für das
gespräch danke dir
[Musik]